you ever give up on someone it's not  about giving up on people it's about  accountability to take responsibility  for oneself I cannot help you if you  cannot be involved to help yourself I  will say to them Point Blank listen if  you're not going to be involved in this  then there's no point to me be involved  this is a team and I'm the only player  here I will always be here  and when you are ready maybe it's just  bad timing I don't know what's good else  is going on in your life and maybe this  is not the right time or maybe I'm a bad  fit but when you are ready I will still  be here no matter what but you have to  call me there's no more me throwing you  the ball